how big of a uh impact did they have
like growing up just knowing that like
there was somebody else from Memphis
that I mean they were nominated for
Oscar you know what I'm saying like
right right right
I mean that would be for the city that
was that was big as hell for the city
like like damn folks then you know the
hustling flow movie like you know what
I'm saying that kind of solidified like
the culture of Memphis like we like like
their movie was real like everything
about that movie was authentic like it's
Memphis right there it was shot in South
Memphis there's Memphis every day all
day
shout out to uh Terence Howard all-time
performance man yeah I believed it yeah
I believe this [__] this [__] was hard
this [__] was hard like this idea